you're watching swipe coming up on this
week's show printing the perfect fit is
this the sound of the future and things
get paranormal in our games routine
hello and welcome to swipe this week
we're at the london-based start-up
behind a new kind of musical instrument
taking off around the world I'll get a
closer look at that later but first
Chris has been checking out the latest
ways 3d printing is helping people with
disabilities including creating
custom-built wheelchairs this is the
world's first 3d printed wheelchair a
prototype that's been 2 years in the
making
the idea is that each individual model
is created based on the user's biometric
data meaning it's made to measure and
can cater for a range of disabilities
and lifestyles there are a lot of aches
and pains and sores and injuries on
injury that are caused by ill-fitting
wheelchairs I'm really free d printing
and scanning and that idea of
translating the human body into digital
data and then a piece of hardware seemed
to answer the brief of being able to
create something really truly bespoke
this product is the first of its kind
but the concept of 3d printing isn't
entirely new when it comes to
wheelchairs some people have been using
the technology to customize existing
models the group hack on wheels sees
people meet regularly to thrash out
ideas and designs for parts to improve
their wheelchairs these are then taken
to a workshop and brought to life
through 3d printing it's a
cost-effective way for them to make
their lives better I was finding it
increasingly difficult and painful to
push my break off and dawn came up with
this after playing around with a few
things and sort of thinking about width
and something that wasn't going to
interfere with the rest of my chair
pushing just makes it so much easier
because when I'm putting my brake on I'm
using all of the heel of my hand and so
there's nothing digging in and causing
me any pain there really isn't anything
like this
over time the group's founder wants to
build an online resource of free to use
shareable designs I think it would be
really amazing to be able to simply go
to your local makerspace in whatever
country you happen to be in go online
access the online library of open-source
designs and print what you need and
other charity groups like motivation
have plans to send 3d printing kits
overseas they already build wheelchairs
in third-world countries and this
technology could speed up production the
thing of 3d printed anything is it seems
to be a new technology and I first heard
of this to do with with artificial limbs
and their and then the way that they're
kind of doing that and it's now opening
up you know artificial limbs to perhaps
countries whether it was for a lot of
people disproportionately expensive and
unaffordable so maybe this will be the
case and you know next for 3d
wheelchairs products like this one
aren't ready for consumers just yet but
with the World Health Organization
estimating there are some 65 million
wheelchair users worldwide there's
certainly a high demand for more
tailored designs Chris Craig and Sky
News stay tuned as we get in tune that's
coming off after a roundup of some of
this week's tech news a drone taxi
capable of carrying one passenger has
reportedly been cleared for test flights
over Nevada in the US the Chinese built
behan 184 it's completely electric and
control
speeds of up to 62 miles per hour it can
only cover short journeys though no
longer than 23 minutes Amazon started
delivering fresh food in the UK this
week the service kicked off in London
but it's already been operating in the
US for nearly a decade Amazon said
customers can order their full weekly
food shop and get a refund if they're
not happy with the freshness a start-up
in Singapore has created what it's
calling the world's smallest astronomy
camera but tiny one fits in the palm of
your hand and is compatible with
telescopes and connects your phone so
you can share your pictures on social
media its makers are raising money on
IndieGoGo to take the camera into
production and new on Kickstarter this
week the watch for children who can't
tell the time yet the octopus shows
pictures indicating when it's time to do
things like eat breakfast and brush
teeth the team behind it says it helps
kids understand time by association
they're fundraising to pay for their
first production run
in a moment we'll be taking a trip to
Morocco with agent 47 stay with us for
our games reveal now about that new kind
of musical instrument I mentioned
earlier this is it this is Roland
playing it beautifully tell me about
this because this is just one part of a
wider seaboard family that's right so
this is the seaboard rise 49 and the
seaboard is a new musical instrument
that's an evolution of the piano
keyboard and so you can play it just the
way you would play a piano but you know
striking each of these different keys
but then in addition you can use
intuitive gestures to control the nature
of the sound after you well for example
once I've struck the note I can then
glide left to right to create a variety
of sensors underneath all that is yeah
this whole thing is a very
information-rich sensor array and so how
whatever micro gesture I use it will
change the sound a little bit is that a
specific material that only works with
that kind of technology this is a kind
of silicon compound that we've created
it you know works with the sensors in
the Seaboard but it also replicates
something of the dynamics of a piano and
keyboard so like when you strike it you
get a little bit of a bounce back and
end it has this raised these raised
things we call key waves which so you
can actually feel where you are even
with your eyes closed so how difficult
is it to invent an entirely new musical
instrument and to get people to pay
attention and actually want to play it
instead of existing instruments well
it's pretty hard and it judge by the
fact that it's very rare so although the
Seaboard is part of the keyboard family
it's actually quite a distant relative
and because it offers so many new
dimensions of touch and of expression
people all around the world are taking
it up and using it and we're excited to
see it really well on its way to
becoming a bonafide musical instrument
people are you know on tour with it and
making albums with it people like Tom
Odell and KT Tunstall and even Stevie
Wonder who's a personal hero of mine now
it's using the C board so it's a pretty
exciting well let's hear some more of
those five-dimensional sounds
all right
from music to games now is what gap has
been playing this week there's been a
lot of fuss about walking simulators
recently in Seoul axiom is one of these
but it's a little bit more involved
basically you're in this world called
ELISA which is kind of like a server for
souls in the afterlife is the best way
that I can explain it which sounds mad I
know and whereas like walking simulators
sort of let the story wash over you in
Soul axiom you're a little bit more
involved because there's a lot of puzzle
things involved it's kind of like
upgrades and things you can find as you
try and figure out exactly what's going
on it's a game from a small company in
Wales for Wales Interactive they've had
a couple of first-person games that are
really sort of taken my interest and it
feels like they're on the cusp of like
really releasing something that's going
to be really really good which I'm
really excited to see so you've heard of
walking simulators oxen-free is kind of
a talking simulator so it's a game which
puts you in control of Alex who's on a
really really small personal journey
with frensley
all of your rooms closed Alex's you
should be careful since she snores like
a truck the way that you experience the
world is not sort of experiencing it by
looking in it it's more like chatting so
a lot of years to do with like dialogue
options and choices that you make so you
interact with different characters and
the way that you interact them it's
gonna pay off so further down the line
it makes you feel really bad about sort
of decisions you make in real life
because you start making these like
small decisions while you think of small
decisions in oxen-free
any day you realize that actually not
all decisions at all and have a massive
bearing on what's going on and that's
kind of what happens in real life as
opposed to it makes you realise actually
maybe you're a bit of a terrible person
but it's really creepy as well because
there's lots of things going on this
really weird radio sort of crackle thing
that you've got going on it's really
hard to talk about without spoiling
there but you're not quite sure what's
going on and even after finishing it I'm
still I'm not that sure but it's only
just my own ps4 so if you have an
experience yet it's an amazing chance to
go
so hit my chapter three sees you in
control of agent 47 again and you're off
to Marrakesh this time now I really like
the way that they're releasing these
games episodically because it gives you
a chance to really sort of take
advantage of the fact that you've only
got access to this one little bit and
it's not lil it's actually pretty big
but you can experience it over and over
again and my favorite thing about it is
you get these like really little
personal stories so my favorite one in
the moment was I was kind of walking
around you had to kill this general and
there's loads of ways of doing it
obviously you can do different kind of
things you can poison him you can go for
like straight-up murdering him with a
knife or a gun but what I did was I kind
of tricked those two guys who were sort
of talking about him behind his back I
switched on a PA system those right next
to them then he ended up here and what
they were saying about him walked over
to them I managed to like sneak around
go up above him and kick a toilet onto
his head and that took him out now I
spoke to a bunch of people and so many
people got different stories about how
they took out this guy and they didn't
have the toilet won so I think by
releasing episodically like this it
gives you a chance to really sort of I
don't know like go in to little small
details and you really feel like you're
in control of what you're doing so I'm
really put for depth so forth
well that's it for this week take a look
at Sky News on mobile tablet catch up
sky queue and snapchat for all the
latest tech stories throughout the week
after you go I'm gonna play out out now